allora
[Musica]
mai
bella questi ragazzi e per il suo video
sono vangelo e oggi siamo su batman non
quello di prima batman quello bello
business signore ho capito di abe nei
bar ci siamo ragazzi batman
questa è la cosa più bella la quale io
potrò mai giocare sul quarto è l'unica
parma lingua ragazzi o dio cioè le max
sono nero sono nero
yo yo pipistrello ragazzi sono sono
tutto nero e forte o anche i guanti
bello possiamo partire si è ma cosa
faccio con lo giu
minchia cioccolato era stato bellissimo
origini premi by light is nothing pesce
o ciardi a ma sono l'anno sono milano
fatemi scritti agno madre e sua madre o
sull'uomo
oh cazzo ci sta a guardare il mare
grosso chi tiene i friends mica per lo
si stima ragazzi ce lo dico la maestra
sì le arti
ancora fortissimo ci ho provato dai mica
che tra i ragazzi sono un trauma medi
giudice alfredo di dio alves pique qui
si può grazie grazie ai tre a zero e
ragazzi bellissima sta roba perché posso
suonare il pianoforte in guarda quindi
grazie ad esso oggi affari si si si
cimenterà nel concerto numero 5 baila vj
grazie sono parte
e stato bello ragazzi è stato bellissimo
e cazzo succede e l'isola sarà basca
verna che figata
chiaramente ragazzi
ciao grazie più terra va bene il libia
che figo però il pacco non è così il
nostro come pensavo posso fare solo fare
è non posso fare così
io sono batman sucate di pipistrelli
la manovra è bellissimo ragazzi miei la
[ __ ] è tutta mia
e bellissimo
oddio sono batman è questa cosa ho
sempre desiderato parla da batman da pj
un movimento sexy è la cintura una mano
la struttura ragazzette la cosa più
bella io ne ho visto c'è lo dico cosa
facciano a parte toccami capezzoli sono
clint eastwood la pistola più potente
del mondo
ah cazzo questo mi serve lo prendo tutto
solo sono messi usate lo usi per
tagliarmi la barba o per affettare il
maiale credo non so denunciare se non
l'abbiamo preso mai nella pizza
all frates valani giocattoli quanto sono
belli fammi un caffè grazie ha mai
pesato su un caricamento non mi sta
portando negli inferi parola madonna la
vecchia mi sento come se dovessi cadere
da un momento all'altro bellissimo
devo fare i compiti facciamo altre due
complici come se ci vai su da regalo
alfred ti avevo chiesto di portarmi del
caffè dove cazzo di un caffè dove sto
totalmente il mio caffè il diana d'armi
caffè d'amico
va bene cosa c'è che cosa vuoi dirmi
hanno capito lo sfigato sarà andato a
[ __ ] perche io c'ero più pointer del
cash quindi a ok
porca eva sono arrivata al bar computer
a computer
che figata erga perché non mi vita oddio
animo che faccio cos'è sta roba
adesso sei sempre argine
adesso mi trovavo lì non sociale è la
vorrebbero data migliore devo deficiente
anche shaun white risponde perché le
storie location il cliente giu andiamo
al centro di gotham city che ci facciamo
un bel perché al preso non è stato in
grado di fare mai così arrivò ai
nightwing devo guidare io avrebbe che
non vado al bar the garage ci vediamo
tra un patto secondo fratello ma una
domanda ragazzi devono guidare mica io
devo guidare io mi sa
vediamo che veicolo scegliamo oh che
bello salette
ma raiola è la macchina la macchina va
bene la macchina fa più che bene la
macchina la macchina perfetto perfetto
già questa sarà difficile devo veramente
guidare i ragazzi grazie al 3 amica mi
sembrava la devo fare che figata suo
studio devono trovare nei più in grado
venne qui c'è chi è stato molto buono
porca eva cosa il teatro con francia e
il bordeaux proprio mac di un mostro in
perenne tecnico e dai fori che è ma che
brutta cosa
che cosa sta succedendo dio
andiamo aspetta aspetta
ok va bene ma lascia amare robin tutto
sto casino
ora sto tirando pugni a caso ciao zio
cosa c'è soldi aspetta aspetta soldi mi
sarei mai immaginato il dollaro perché
senti pinguino visto che alcuni dei
soldi non sei stato tu e chi è stato
chiesa di cristo
vabbè va bene va bene va bene sono
girati da qualcuno mi sono caga tissimo
questo mi sono stato davvero muoversi
base
bravo 3 devo scappare
mi scusi devo scappare fatto piacere
alla prossima 0 e stato un piacere ma
comunque ragazzi se comunque ragazzi se
vogliamo proprio essere pignoli e non è
che ho preso batman perché devo
ispezionare dei cadaveri e se non è che
siamo qua a pettinare le carcasse
comunque c'è scritto il nome di tutti
che adesso mi faccio il chirurgo di
turno ragazzi dovrebbero fare il saggio
un simulato riguarda sapete figo faccio
io come lo taglio anno devo scusarmi
che schifo vuol dire che se faccio così
posso anche guardare cosa accesso perché
non c'è una vera signora in questo
momento devo proprio a vedere che cosa
c'è possono dai raga non posso
vabbè e facciamo che evitiamo questa
zona e quindi andiamo dall'altra parte
che venivano il fermo che dal femore
dove tembre qua eccola la prendo con la
mano con la mano ha così anche nei
somatiche tenerlo ag tenete al mass
effect 3 è adesso ha finito di fare loro
state altro anno e the man in più famosi
quale vittime odio no vi prego basta non
sono potuto ispezionato le dica dal sun
e ascolti e lei è molto bello vorremmo
solo dirle che io non sono proprio bravo
a ispezionare i cadaveri quindi vanno in
giro e buona giornata grazie papà è che
posso muovermi così mi scusi ma non
intendevo fender lanzi deco vabbè se lo
cerchi mi servirebbe capire cos'è sarà
un codice non ma un cazzo e devo aprire
qua e come lo apro spiegami i rapporti
con le due mani deficiente
niente non fosse letta chi in saint don
trans the cleaners tirchio alfheim
iwatch ok
non a chiave quindi da qualche parte
dove sta chiave ma che deficente me ne
posso vedere attraverso le cose quindi
anno attraverso questo no [ __ ] la
maiala allora niente caccia marca come
faccio a vedere qua dentro dove la trovo
st chiave maledetta
sono un po tutto genio ci sono arrivato
da solo mica e culo è per carità allora
425 perfetto poteva essere anche 4 5 2
ma io ho avuto culo bene grazie questo
6223 infilerei però non ce l'ha il culo
zio purtroppo è perfetto appetiti po
come quando cucini il porno che lo tiri
fuori dal forno
ecco ben salve devo esaminare corpo mi
scusi se la importuno in questo momento
però perfetto ho analizzato record
vorrei dire cosa sta succedendo figlio
mi hanno capito cosa devo fare li
spaventa però che devo usare questi cosi
pieni mangia a devi metterli insieme va
bene allora fermi sono bravo io in
queste cose
perfetto ha apposto anno ad hoc è il
perfetto fatto fatto ferito perfetto
quelle lavorate uscita amiche dal cu lo
zio perché dall uscita dice no erano i
pizzini cose che ho trovato dei suoi
corpi bene ho capito per trovare
è una trappola isomar prendendo cento
ovviamente lui ti dice che una trappola
e tu che cosa dice sto arrivando sei un
[ __ ] genio va bene va bene tutta la
barca sembra lo sapevo io mi scusi mi dà
una mano che il mio amico robin è morto
qua dentro
entriamo siamo alle fogne agazzi premier
che una trappola quindi inutile giocare
veramente infatti vedere il predetto
stronzo non è che se sei già registrato
fai ci siamo
meno male che ti fanno cagare i
pipistrelli mi fa cagare palo dove sei
uno stronzo
dai dai dai propri come dividono ma
credo lo so io sono un [ __ ] mela che
mi ha anche detto lo so c'è stand
informativi lo so siamo tutti e due
[ __ ] che ci vuoi per chi sei
ecco la peggio chiama non va una setta
maya
tieni in questo giocattolo è come faccio
a manama
ok è stato dario regazzoni e che per ora
posso concludere qui l'episodio e lascia
a metà perché non voglio che mi squadra
dato il continuo perché continua in un
modo molto più figo di quello che avete
visto prova è una bomba e una [ __ ] fa
è bellissimo spero che mi sia piaciuto
ragazzi non se ne sa momento mi piace il
fatto di sapere se volete continua
notizia che ci picchiamo fossero i
ragazzi
[Musica]